bonsoir et bienvenue très heureuse de
vous retrouver dans Ça vous regarde ce
soir qu'est-ce que la diplomatie
féministe bonsoir Delphine ha bonsoir et
merci d'être notre grand témoin ce soir
vous êtes ambassadrice itinérante pour
le qu d'orset chargé de défendre le
droit des femmes dans le monde c'est une
action méconnue qui mérite une
explication que vous expliquez dans
votre premier livre la diplomatie
féministe un sport de combat chez
taayandier tableau géopolitique des
droits des femmes dans le monde attaqué
de toutes parts on en parle toutes les
deux tout à l'heure dans la 2è partie
relaxé c'est notre grand débat ce soir
Éric Dupont Moretti a été blanchi par la
Cour de Justice de la République après
15 jours de procès intense les juges en
majorité des parlementaires n'ont pas
suivi l'accusation de prise illégale
d'intérêt la justice est donc passé mais
la neutralité même de cette cour est
toujours contestée ce soir on en parle
dans un instant sur ce plateau avec mes
invités enfin nos affranchis ce soir le
billet société de Cécilia gabizon
l'économie avec Thomas Lestavel et puis
Bourbon express de Stéphanie des
piierres voilà pour le menu on y va
dafino ça vous regarde c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite l'horizon politique s'éclaircit
donc pour Éric Dupont Moretti le garde
des saau a été reçu ce soir par Emmanuel
Macron les juges principalement des
parlementaires de la Cour de Justice de
la République n'ont pas retenu
l'accusation de prise illégale d'intérêt
porté contre lui par des syndicats de
magistrats il est donc relaxé on va
revenir dans le détail sur cette
décision extrêmement attendue et puis
sur les leçons qu'on peut tirer de ce
procès hors norme pour l'avenir bonsoir
Alexis izarons et merci d'être là vous
êtes député renaissance de on
porte-parole de votre groupe
parlementaire à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir Charles de Courson bonsoir ravi
de vous accueillir député Liot de la
Marne ancien membre de la Cour de
Justice de la République ce qui va nous
être utile pour comprendre le secret des
délibérés comment ça se passe qu'est-ce
qu'on vote comment ça comment ça se
passe très concrètement bonsoir Anne
Charlen beina bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous vous êtes constitutionnaliste et
maître de conférence en droit public à
l'université de rouan enfin bonsoir
Mathieu de lase et merci d'être là vous
êtes grand à l'OPS et vous avez suivi
l'intégralité de ces 15 jours de de
procès inédit pour un un ministre de la
Justice en exercice vous nous direz s'il
y a eu un moment de bascule ou pas pour
pour les pour les juges évidemment
Delphino vous intervenez quand vous
voulez si vous le souhaitez on commence
par ce jugement ausculté de très près
par Stéphane blackakowski c'est le
chrono blco tout de
suite et je me retourne pour vous
accueillir mon cher Stéphane bonsoir je
vous invite à faire la même chose
bonsoir à toutes et tous alors alors
j'avais prévu une accroche en disant
acquitator a été acquitté en fait ça
marche pas parce qu'il a été relaxé j'ai
appris qu'en fait on était acquité
devant une cour d'assise quand c'est la
Cour de Justice de la République qui
reconnaît votre innocence vous êtes
relaxé donc petit rappel des fait pour
ceux qui aurait oublié YC Dupont
morétier était accusé de prise illégale
d'intérêt c'està veut dire d'avoir
profité d'être nommé ministre de la
Justice pour se venger de magistrat avec
qui il était en conflit lorsqu'il était
avocat donc lors du procès vous voyez
que le procureur avait demandé au juge
de reconnaître coupable le ministre de
la justice il avait même requis un an de
prison avec surcis et il a donc été
désavoué par les juges 15 juges dont 12
sont des parlementaires peut-être qu'on
aura l'occasion de reparler de la
composition euh de la sgè mais en
attendant euh quand on lit euh les les
motivations du jugement on se rend
compte que la décision de la CGR est
assez subtile enfin en tout cas à mes
yeux en effet les juges ne contestent
pas qu'il y ait une prise illégale
d'intérêt mais ils n'ont pas condamné le
ministre de la justice parce que ils
n'avent pas fait exprès alors moi je dis
ça comme ça peut-être pas bon terme vous
allez voir comment c'est formulé par la
justice c'est jamais tout à fait clair
voilà ce que disent les juges la
connaissance de l'existence de
situations objective de conflit
d'intérêt par les différentes autorités
appelées à le conseiller n'établissent
pas la conscience suffisante qu'il
pouvait avoir de commettre un délit
alors moi j'aurais tendance à traduire
ça on lui a dit à plusieurs reprises
qu'il y avait des risques de conf
d'intérêt mais lui n'en était pas
vraiment conscient donc on ne saurait le
condamner pour cette raison c'est
d'ailleurs voilà ce qui est dit plus
encore formellement par la suite dans le
même motivation à défaut de
caractérisation donc de l'élément
intentionnel de délit prise égal
d'intérêt les infractions ne sont pas
constitué puisque c'est pas intentionnel
et donc le ministre est relaxé alors on
imaginait évidemment que après cette
bonne nouvelle Éric Dupont moriti
viendrait devant la presse se réjouir et
puis vous allez voir que c'est pas du
tout le cas en fait on a été un peu
surpris alors que ça sorti bah écoutez
tout un peu lent parce que voyez on
imagine qu'il va se précipiter sur les
micros et pas du tout en réalité il
passe royalement devant la presse sans
jeter un regard journaliste donc il sera
ce soir au 20h de France 2 mais à la
sortie de l'audience c'était son avocate
qui s'exprimait en l'écoute c'est
évidemment une satisfaction et je dirais
même une émotion
énorme la Cour de Justice de la
République a jugé que le ministre de la
Justice Éric Dupont Moretti était
innocent alors de leur côté les les
avocats l'avocat qui défendait les
syndicats de magistrats qui ont porté
plainte contre le ministre à l'origine
cherchait un motif de satisfaction
malgré tout dans la décision du tribunal
et donc eux ils constatent que les juges
ont reconnu le fait qu'il y avait une
prise illégale d'intérêt dans ce cas-là
qu' y avait un vrai conflit d'intérêt
entre le ministre et les magistrats
contre lequel il a obar une enquête s'il
a pas été condamné c'est que c'est la
Cour de Justice de la République qui
fonctionne mal on écoute la procédure
devant la Cour de Justice de la
République est une procédure imparfaite
nous souhaitons pour l'avenir que cette
imperfection de notre système juridique
pour une cour de justice qui est
essentielle au fonctionnement de la
République soit corrigée bref voilà le
dossier sur la suppression de la Cour de
Justice de la République refait son
apparition je vous rappelle qu'il avait
déjà été envisagé et par François
Hollande et par Emmanuel Macron alors
est ce que le débat est relancé ben à
vous de me dire he et ben évidemment
qu'il est relancé et et dès ce soir
merci beaucoup Stéphane je vais
commencer avec vous Mathieu de laous
parce que vous avez suivi ce procès de
près déjà est-ce que vous êtes surpris
par ce jugement non on n'est pas surpris
par le jugement pour pour deux raisons
c'est que il y avait une forme
d'accusation qui était soutenue de façon
très forte contre rrig du poretti mais
lui avait une stratégie de défense qui
était très efficace qui se résume par un
seul élément qui était le fait j'ai
suivi mon administration qui est une
phrase qu'il a répété comme un mantra à
plusieurs reprises et qui effectivement
en terme de responsabilité pénale
était une forme d'évidence qui j'ai
suivi mon administration pour bien
comprendre l'administration judiciaire
lui demandait de digentter ces fameuses
enquêtes contre les quatre magistrats on
va aller voir d'ailleurs à l'ANT s'ffich
et le deuxième aspect qui fait partie de
l'une des particularités de la Cour de
Justice de la République qu'il faudra
peut-être évoquer c'est qu'effectivement
dans la salle nombreuses étaient les
personnes qui avaient eu des rumeurs qui
faisait que ce jugement commençait à
transpercer par les murs de cette mais
par la par les murs du palais du
Luxembourg également sur une une
décision qui serait favorable au au
ministre donc la surprise n'a pas été
une stupéfaction énorme dans la salle au
moment où la décision de semaines il
peut se passer beaucoup de choses on a
parlé du procureur près la C cassation
Remi on a parlé de Jean Castex qui est
venu aussi est-ce qu'il y a eu un moment
de bascule est-ce qu'il y a eu un
tournant qui ont emporté les les
décisions des juges le le la
construction de l'audience en réalité a
a montré ce qui s'était déroulé au
niveau des magistrats qui ont été la
cible de ces poursuites disciplinaires
et qu' l'ont été effectivement avec le
sentiment très fort et que personne ne
pourra leur enlever que ces poursuites
étaient diligentées en raison de ce
qu'ils avaient fait comme magistrat
contre l'avocat Éric dupomoretti ou
contre contre ses clients mais la
deuxième partie ça a été la défense
d'Éric dupomti c'était peu exprimé
jusque-l et moi comme je l'ai écrit dans
les contte-rendus dans l'OPS on présente
souvent cette affaire comme binaire si
vous voulez c'est soit un règlement de
compte des magistrats contre leurs
ministres soit au contraire un ministre
qui aurait tout manipulé à sa main et
cetera il y a une troisième voix qui est
plus complexe qui est peut-être moins
sédivisante dans la dramaturgie
romanesque qui entoure toujours Éric
Dupont Moretti mais c'est finalement une
forme d'incompétence d'unpréparation que
lui-même a revendiqué et finalement que
l'on retrouve dans le jugement
d'aujourd'hui en il faut comprendre bien
et je veux juste raconter qui était le
celle de dire j'arrive j'étais avocat
j'arrive ministre de la Justice de façon
assez surprenante pour chacun mais y
compris pour pour moi-même et je n'ai
pas eu le temps de me préparer à cette
discipline gouvernementale sur les
conflit d'intérêts raison pour laquelle
je n'ai pas pris de de précaution pas
pris de décret de déport et finalement
décret de déport qui vudrait dire que il
n'aurait pu il aurait pu ne pas décider
lui-même en tant que garde des SA parce
qu'il avait porté plainte avant de
l'être garde des saut pour cette affaire
d'écoute et donc il était ces factures
détaillé avait été demandé par les
magistrats et donc il aurait dû et ça il
il a reconnu plutôt se déporter demander
par exemple à Matignon de de prendre la
décision à sa place voilà son le
raisonnement qui est encore une fois le
raisonnement de la défense et qui était
assez nouveau mais qui et a été
aujourd'hui suivi par la Cour de Justice
de la République c'est de mettre en
avant cette forme euh d'ignorance du
danger du conflit d'intérêt qui pouvait
se se présenter de ne pas avoir pris de
de précaution quand on l'entend à
l'audience on on peut s'en étonner euh
la l'accusation qui est portée par le
procureur général Remy effectivement ne
croit pas du tout à cette hypothèse on
est au ministère de la Justice on est
avec l'un des avocats les plus
talentueux du moment on est avec un
secrétariat général du gouvernement qui
existe on est avec une autre Haute
Autorité de la transparence de la vie
politique qui existe depuis 10 ans quand
même en France malgré tout effectivement
la Cour de Justice de la République cet
après-midi a reconnu ce raisonnement
comme étant celui qui devait arriver et
aboutir à la relax Charles de Courçon le
conflit la situation de conflit
d'intérêt a bien été reconnue par la
justice mais pas la prise illégale
d'intérêt parce qu'erc dupourmetti
n'aurait pas profité de cette situation
pour régler ses comptes avec les quatre
magistrats qu'on a vu trois du PNF un un
juge d'instruction en tout cas preuve de
l'intentionnalité n'a pas été faite
c'est même plus compliqué que cela
puisque ce qui est incompréhensible par
un citoyen de base c'est de reconnaître
que le conflit d'intérêt était constitué
mais le fait que il navait pas
suffisamment
conscience de la prise illégale
d'intérêt il est relaxé vous avourez que
expliquer ça à l'opinion publique c'est
quand même pas simple et je pense que
cette faire quel que soit son issue
affaibli encore un peu plus l'image de
la justice dans notre pays et
affaibli la République
Z et je suis de ceux qui ont toujours
plaidé pour la suppression de la CGR
puisque qu'est-ce que va dire l'opinion
publique bah c'est un arrangement entre
amis politiqueirtail comme d'habitude et
on a entendu ça sur
X décisions de la c'est Jr on a envie de
savoir et je continue le tour de table
comment se passent les délibérations
vous avez siégé de nombreuses années
dans cette cour de justice de la
République comme député magistrat dans
de nombreuses affaires il y a il y a des
votes à la fin pour décider de sera le
jugement comment comment ça se passe ça
se passe en deux temps c'est-à-dire il y
a les accusations qui sont portées donc
on fait un premier vote sur ce qu'on
appelle est-il responsable de ce dont on
l'accuse voilà premier vote alors grande
discussion chacun donne son opinion on
tourne on est 15 donc ça prend du temps
et après on vote voilà s'il y a une
majorité et ben il est reconnu coupable
s'il y a une majorité en sens inverse on
va pas plus loin s'il est reconnu
coupable deuxème phase de la manœuvre le
quantum de la peine alors comme il y a
plusieurs peines voyez
l'inégibilité la prison euh des amendes
hein voilà alors pour chacune d'entre
elles on discute et après on vote euh en
décroissant de mémoire voyez et dès
qu'il y a une majorité voilà on arrête
le curseur par exemple on dit il va y
avoir de la on va le condamner de la
prison alors discussion avec surcis ou
sans surcis vous voyez et et et donc on
dégrade certains disent 1 an donc on
fait le tour de table donc c'est c'est
des votes il y a pas une sorte de
consensus qui doit émerger c'est
intéressant de le savoir parce que les
audiences sont publiques mais évidemment
lesations sont sec le délibéré il est
secret bien sûr V et on fait le tour des
15 chacun donne son opinion ce qui est
drôle c'est que parfois les opinions des
uns rétroagissent après sur sur les
autres lors des votes successifs et et
on vote comme ça ou celui qui aé avant
peut avoir une influence surelès il y a
toute la rédaction alors là ça prend du
temps et on sera réuni pour bien
vérifier que voilà c'est bien ce qu' a
décidé la CGR voilà comment ça bizarre
c'est la justice qui a gagné c'est la
présomption d'innocence qui a gagné
aujourd'hui pour vous je crois qu'oui il
a PR le soulagement de la macronie la
présomption d'innocence elle sort
grandit de cette affaire là parce que
pendant de nombreux mois il y a eu une
pression pour faire démissionner ce
ministre qui finalement ressort relaxé
de cette affaire là il faut rappeler ce
que c'est que cette affaire c'est un
ministre qui est alors qu'un simple
avocat qui subit de la part de du PNF
qui d'ailleurs un rapport vient après
dire que la manière don financier
parquet national financier donc ils ont
agi était si ce n'est illégal an normal
pour récupérer ce qu'on appelait les
fadet donc c'est relevé téléphonique
donc savoir ce que faisait le ministre
pour suivre une affaire le ministre
porte plainte quand il découvre ça on
est en juin 20 est avocat on est en juin
2020 un mois après il devient garde des
saau vous l'avez dit peut-être à sa
propre surprise à la surprise de
l'opinion publique il devient ministre
qu'est-ce qu'il fait il se demande
est-ce que c'est bien raisonnable de
garder la plainte non il décide de
retirer sa plainte alors il s'avère
qu'il récupère sur son bureau ce rapport
qu'il n'avait même pas demandé mais il
récupère ce rapport sur son bureau qui
dit qu'effectivement il était victime
d'une affaire assez anormale et donc ce
qu'on lui reproche ici et on lui
demandait de Me démissionner pour ça
c'est que il était victime d'un corps de
magistrat qui voulait le faire tomber
qui voulait le faire tomber si si il
faut le dire parce que pendant de
nombreux mois on a voulu faire tomber le
garde des saau aujourd'hui le relaxer et
je crois que c'est une c'est une bonne
chose en tout cas pour la présomption
d'innocence de dire que cette cette
arrêt cette décision elle était
importante et aujourd'hui elle est
importante pour les Français mon cher
collègue c'est tout à fait exact ce que
vous dites pour une raison très simple
c'est que les intéressés les magistrats
intéressés ont été
euh reconnu absolument pas coupable de
ce dont le le le garde saau du temps où
il était avocat les a accusé oui mais ça
c'est une autre histoire le rapport dit
bien que vous dit vous dites que c'est
un
magistrat alors je n'ai pas dit le mot
complot c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
dit j'ai dit que le rapport le rapport
sur le le PNF visait bien et montrait
bien qu'il y avait un dfonctionnement
dans dans les méthodes qui ét utilisé à
l'encre alors an Charl Benina pardon
est-ce que vous vous avez l'impression
que cette justice qui a qui bien
expliqué dans son fonctionnement par
Charles de courourson sort grandie sort
gagnante de cet épisode moi je crois que
c'est un des problèmes ontologiques de
la CJR et peut-être que si on remonte
dans l'histoire et et dans dans dans le
droit constitutionnel c'est presque un
problème épistémologique avec cette idée
de juger le politique on est dans
quelque chose qui de toute façon aux
yeux de l'opinion a beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent apparaître insatisfaisantes
notamment parce que il y a déjà ce
problème d'accessibilité au droit on l'a
dit ici on nous parle d'éléments
intentionnels il faut savoir que tout le
monde ne sait pas qu'un délit est
constitué d'un élément matériel la
situation de faite et d'un élément
intentionnel c'est-à-dire est-ce que
moralement vous avez l'intention de
commettre le délit et ces éléments-là
toute cette complexité déjà elle
apparaît dans ce système de justice mais
il y a autre chose c'est que le problème
de la Cour de Justice de la République
c'est évidemment de faire une place aux
politiques dans le jugement et vous avez
employé tout à l'heure pour désigner
monsieur de Courson le mot magistrat
député ou député magistrat et on voit
bien déjà dans cette coloration à quel
point on a quelque chose qui peut
apparaître pour les citoyens un peu
anormal à deux vitesses et cetera et je
crois que la justice en sort grandi
aujourd'hui par rapport au fait qu'une
décision de justice a été rendue et on
pourra enfin apaiser les esprits sur
cette question mais la vie politique ne
l'est pas nécessairement étant donné que
déjà c'est une atteinte à l'honneur il y
a quelque chose qui fait que aujourd'hui
cette affaire a existé on a vu un
ministre en justice et quelle que soit
la décision étant donné plus la trac
pour vous elle laisse des traces
notamment parce que on est dans quelque
chose de totalement feuilletonnesque le
délit de prise illégale d'intérêt qui
déjà est très difficile à caractériser
un avocat qui devient ministre de la
justice il faut savoir que ce ministère
c'est un ministère absolument
particulier comme celui de l'éducation
où vous avez à diriger les juges mais
aussi les avocats et que les deux
familles ne s'entendent guerre
précisément l'un joue toujours un petit
peu le jeu contre l'autreou la situation
ét le
procureur cassation qui va pororter
l'accudation à son ministre de tutelle
sachant qu'il il l'a nommé qu'il a une
pouvoir de décision sur les nominations
on avait jamais vu ça est-ce que déjà
démocratiquement ça pose pas un problème
ça posait un problème dès le départ et
ça en pose encore un aujourd'hui sur la
légitimité de la Cour de Justice de la
République mais je pense queil faut pas
forcément s'égarer aujourd'hui sur
toutes les sousaffaires qu'on a voulu
exploiter comme des écrans de fumée pour
la défense des Res du PTI dans cette
dans ce dossier il faut aussi
reconnaître que c'est une décision qui
doit s'imposer à nous tous les
magistrats plignants qui effectivement
ont été blanchis par le Conseil
supérieur de la magistrature ont accepté
de participer entre guillemets à ce jeu
judiciaire la décision a été rendue par
un ministre qui est venu se défendre et
qui a accepté de jouer sur ce jeu
judiciaire la décision qui a été rendue
vous le connaissez puisque vous avez
occupé ce poste par les juges
parlementaires ce sont des juges qui se
mettez en robe ça a été votre cas l juge
qui ont prêté serment et qui sont
désignés par les bureaux du Sénat et de
l'Assemblée nationale et cette décision
a été rendue et juste pour terminer
cette idée qui à mon avis est assez
importante c'est que effectivement la
Cour de Justice de la République a été
contestée par chacun mais la décision ce
soir est rendue et c'est comme ça
qu'elle est rédigée par le magistrat et
qu'elle a été adoptée lors du vote par
par les parlementaires et les magistrats
elle est rendue au nom du peuple
français avec effectivement des tas
d'imperfection mais c'est vrai qu'elle
elle s'impose dans son côté binaire
auour aujourd'hui on était soit relaxé
soit condamné soit ministre soit pas
ministre elle est totalement
légaleralement elle est totalement lé
mais c'est vrai que dans en tout cas
dans dans ces particularités multiples
elle au-delà de ce constat que la
décision s'impose on est obligé de
s'interroger sur sur cette cour en
particul la décision qui a été rendue
sur cette composition de la cour et
cette situation totalement inédite et
ubuesque d'avoir un ministre qui est
venu en exercice répondre avec des
avocats face à un procureur général qui
l'avait choisi c'est c'est lui qui l'a
choisi éc dupom est-il le procureur
général c'est pas lui qui a signé le
décret parce il y avait effectivement
une décision de déport sur sur Matignon
mais on est en tout cas dans quelque
chose qui est dans une anormalité
fascinante mais tout le monde a accepté
de jouer le le jeu le prévenu les
plaignants magistrats qui n'avaient même
pas le droit d'être parti civile donc
ils étaient dans une place c'est RG je
particul dans un jeu inédit mais que
tout le monde a accepté donc
effectivement aujourd'hui cette décision
posose à tous au nom du peuple français
avec 1000 imperfections qu'il faut
débattre pour ce jugement mais aussi
pour l'avenir alors on y va sur l'avenir
puisqu'on a tous bien compris très vite
c'est cette Cour de Justice de la
République qui est pointée du doigt
principalement par l'opposition tour
d'horizon des réactions avec ela mangava
et on reprend le débat juste
après dès l'annonce de la relaxe du
garde des sauts la gauche réclame la
suppression de la Cour de Justice de la
République cette juridiction est suect
par nature par construction c'est une
forme de gigantesque prise illégale
d'intérêt en soi le jugement a été donné
il sera respecté mais il y a quand même
est-ce qu'il rétablit la confiance j'en
doute des parlementaires qui jugent un
ministre ça renvoie l'image de l'entre
soi principale GRI donc sa composition
même TR magistrats et 12 parlementaires
députés et sénateurs pour la droite pas
de décision active mais une réflexion
plus globale faut-il comme ça à chaud
décider qu'il faut mettre à terre la
Cour de Justice de la République je n'en
suis pas certain qu'il faille travailler
durablement et profondément à restaurer
la confiance entre les citoyens et
globalement les institutions y compris
l'institution judiciaire c'est une
évidence absolue dans la majorité on
considère que c'est surtout la décision
de la Cour de Justice de la République
que les oppositions n'acceptent pas on
nurait peut-être pas eu le même son de
cloche si jamais Éric dupomti avait
évidemment été condamné je crois qu'on a
face aux oppositions des mauvais joueurs
pour autant on rappelle que la
suppression de la Cour de Justice de la
République était une promesse d'Emmanuel
Macron réforme de la Constitution était
prévu en 2018 mais les équilibres
politiques n'ont pas été trouvés à
l'avenir peut-être que ce sujet peut
revenir sur la table et si tel est le
cas je ferai partie de ceux qui
plaidront effectivement pour changer le
système Emmanuel Macron François
Hollande avant lui tous les deux avaient
promis de supprimer la Cour de Justice
de la République sans y arriver pour le
faire il faut une réforme de la
Constitution et donc un large accord
politique alexiszar promesse
présidentielle c'est pas le premier
Emmanuel Macron tous ont voulu quasiment
la supprimer personne ne l'a fait
honnêtement c'est peine perdue d'ouvrir
ce chantier c'est trop tard non non je
pense ni que ce soit trop tard ni que ce
soit à peine perdu il faut faire
attention sur cette Cour de Justice de
la République rappele pourquoi elle
existe c'est parce qu'il y a une
séparation des pouvoirs et qu'il faut
faire attention de pas déséquilibrer
cette séparation du pouvoir mais même le
président estime que sa composition avec
les parlementaires jette le soupçon sur
là-dessus moi je veux revenir sur sur
quel de quel soupçon on parle on parle
donc d'une composition de 15 15
magistrats dont 12 parlementaire dedans
la composition même temps six sont à
l'Assemblée nationale six sont au Sénat
dans ces 12 parlementaires CIN sont de
la majorité que je représente
c'est-à-dire que la majorité est
extrêmement minoritaire dans cette
assemblée- là dans cette assemblé vous
avez dans cette assemblée vous avez des
magistrats France insoumis des
magistrats rassemblement national dont
on pe on ne peut pas dire que euh le
garde des saau soit en mais le soupçon
peut poser des deux côtés on pourrait
imaginer que l'opposition uniquement par
opposition partisane soit partiale et
ben je peux vous dire que oui on peut
l'imaginer et pour autant pour autant et
pour autant on voit bien que là malgré
les oppositions les magistrats
parlementaires et les magistrats ont
jugé sur le fond cette affaire là et je
trouve ça plutôt rassurant je trouve
qu'elle a plutôt bien fonctionné alors
peut-être que moi je suis du côté de la
majorité et je suis plutôt heureux de la
relaxe de notre garde d' saut mais
forceé de constater que nous n'avions
pas la majorité en tout cas dans ce dans
ces 15 magistrats et pour autant sur le
fond ils ont jugé la relaxe d'un
ministre qui pourtant il décriait
Charles de Courson s'il faut la
supprimer on sait que vous militez pour
la supprimer par quoi la remplacerpp il
faut rappeler qu'elle a été créée en 93
elle a été créée en 93 sur l'affaire du
sang contaminé puisqueà l'époque les
ministres n'étaient responsables que
devant la Haute Cour de Justice et la
Haute Cour de justice il n'était
condamnable que si il elles avaient
commis un crime de haute trahison a vous
dire que la haute cour elle été faite
pour ne jamaiselle n'a jamais fonctionné
elle peut pas fonctionner donc on a créé
pour le Premier ministre et les
ministres cette Cour de Justice de la
République après beaucoup de débats moi
j'ai participé j'ai fait partie des
premiers hein et sur le sang contaminé
mais j'étais juge suppléant donc je peux
en parler parce que j'ai prêté serment
de ne jamais révéler le secret des
délibérés bien mais j'ai pas participeré
au délibéré puisque j'était juge
suppléant et ce qui m'a frappé tout de
suite c'est le caraè
politique et moi ma ma ma conviction
elle est faite elle est faite non non
mais je je dirai rien je pourrais vous
raconter que en 93 elle est constituée
on se réunit pour le le débat qui était
quand même une affaire très difficile du
sans contaminé et des collègues de la
minorité de
l'époque nous disons à tous hein de
toute façon on votera contre la
responsabilité hein et vous serez bien
content quand ça sera votre tour qu'on
fasse la même chose c'est pas une
justice et de toute façon bah oui je
peux en témoigner et mais précisément
dans la même AFF je suis le dernier
survivant de la Cour de justice de 93
voilà il y en a pas d'autres bien et
donc je peux le dire aujourd'hui hein je
ne travaille pas le secret délibéré
c'est pas le secret délibéré on était
même pas encore rentré dans j'allais
dire dans l'émicycle à l'époque bon et
donc moi ma position elle n'est pas euh
celle-là elle est la composition le
problème c'est la composition et je
pense qu'il faut euh que les ministres
ils soient jugés dans des conditions de
droit commun c'estàd de conserver les
deux les deux mécanismes euh de de tri
hein pour éviter euh parce que si tout
le monde on peut y avoir des milliers de
recours qu'on maintienne les deux
institutions euh qui sont fait hein pour
trier les les les vraies questions voilà
et qu'on renvoie ça devant les tribunaux
euh de droit commun parce qu'en plus on
a un problème dont on n pas parlé parce
que dans le cas présent il ne se posait
pas c'est le problème des membres des
cabinets ministériel par rapport au
ministres parce que les membres des
cabinets ministériel ils relèvent du
droit commun et on a vu parfois des
décisions contradictoires entre les
décisions de la juridiction de droit
commun qui allait condamner le directeur
de cabinet qui avait signé B des actes
irrégulier et cetera et euh devant la
Cour de justice relaxe du ministre ça
c'est pas possible alors char il faut
une réforme constitutionnelle pour
changer cette cour autant dire un
mission impossible dans l'état actuel de
la composition de l'Assemblée nationale
mais quelles sont les pistes pas
forcément madame arri à faire consensus
on va dire sur ce seul problème voyez
sur ce seul problème on pourrait trouver
une 35è des parlementaires moi je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de courants
politiques qui pensent que il ne faut
plus qu'il y ait de juges
parlementair en tout cas c'est vrai que
la Cour de Justice de la R publ fait un
peu l'unanimité contre elle ça je je
vous rejoins largement néanmoins il faut
pas non plus avoir le sentiment qu'on
est passé de de tout ou rien vous
rappeliez l'existence de la hautee Cour
de justice qui était quand même composé
exclusivement parlementaire he c'est
l'Assemblée nationale et le Sénat donc
on n' jamais pour précisément donc en
fait on est parti de de de rien on a eu
pas grand-chose et peut-être qu'on
pourra avoir quelque chose
maintenantiton s'inspirer pourit
justement
éviterteons politique et pénale de ces
gouvernants tout simplement parce queon
est assez hostile et ça c'est 1791 c'est
aussi notre manière de faire de la
politique à l'idée que les responsables
politiques et que les mandats en réalité
ne soient pas protégés vous avez les
systèmes latino-américains où par
exemple le président de la République
est à peu près att tré en justice tous
les qu matins et c'est vrai que c'est un
système que la France ne n'a jamais
souhaité faire sien donc il y a une très
forte conception de la séparation des
pouvoirs néanmoins cette séparation là
des pouvoirs elle a aussi un autre
corollaire constitutionnel qui est le
principe d'égalité devant la justice et
j'ajoute que la Cour de Justice de la
République quand elle a été créée en 93
elle a été créée pour satisfaire
l'opinion pour des besoins je cite le
rapport Vedel qui l' a créé de
transparence aujourd'hui on nous a parlé
de la Haute Autorité de la transparence
pour la vie politique l'éthique
gouvernementale la Haute Autorité de la
transparence malheureusement elle n'a
qu'un chef de compétences très fin euh
les patrimoines par exemple euh les
conflits d'intérêts et encore lorsqu'ils
sont déclarés donc ouud c'est c'est tout
le problème d'ailleurs hein dans cette
affaire se demande à qui la faute est-ce
que la Haute Autorité poser la question
de de la moralisation de la vie
politique et publique il faut se
rappeler qu'Emmanuel Macron a été élu
sur ce programme que François Baou qui
était son premier ministre de la justice
devait mener cette grande campagne de la
moralisation par une réforme
constitutionnelle qui comprenait
justement la suppression de cette cour
de justice donc je pense que le problème
est bien plus large qu'il faut
aujourd'hui accepter peut-être que en
effet des tribunaux de droit commun
jugent les ministres mais il a fallu un
cheminement intellectuel pour en arriver
là et rappelons quand même vous parliez
de de l'existence des de fits je crois
qu'ils sont nécessaires une commission
des requêtes vient déjà filtrer les
recours contre les parlementaires je
veux dire contre les ministres et ce
filtrage là il a quelque chose
d'important donc de toute façon le droit
commun ne sera pas vraiment du droit
commun eu égard précisément à cette
particularité historique de la France
oui on entend beaucoup monter aussi
attention à
l'hyperjudiciarisation des responsables
politique le risque pénal les pandémie
tout ça doit se régler dans les urnes
par les citoyens et par et pas par la la
justice je voudrais Mathieu de Laou ce
que vous nous expliquez tout à l'heure
vous vous commenciez à expliquer que
avec cette cour de justice les règles ne
sont pas exactes les mêmes par exemple
il y a pas de partie civile c'est ça
comment ça se déroule ça rejoint
exactement ce qui vient d'être expliqué
de de façon très claire sur
effectivement l'équilibre des partis
alors on a l'habitude quand on traite
les affaires judiciaaires d'avoir un
accusateur et quelqu'un qui qui se
défend mais on a aussi toute cette phase
qui est extrêmement spectaculaire qui
est la phase de l'enquête et la phase de
l'enquête on est dans une opposition
entre effectivement la justice et
l'exécutif de façon très nette et sur
les droits on pourra parler des civile
mais il y a eu un aspect presque
souterrain de cette Cour de Justice de
la République qu'on évoque assez peu
c'est la phase d'enquête et cette phase
d'enquête elle n'est pas du tout aux
mains des parlementaires elle est aux
mains des magistrats et c'est celle-là
qui a traumatisé si je puis dire sans
excès et sans ironie l'exécutif ce sont
les perquisition mené au ministère de la
Justice au mois de de juillet 2021 à la
même période dans la crise sanitaire
chez Olivier verrant chez Édouard
Philippe qui venait de quitter Matignon
où une perquisition s'est déroulée à son
domicile et cet aspect-l euh finalement
est vécu par le politique comme une
grande violence comme des enquêtes
extrêmement intrusives et je termine
juste par ce point parce que c'était
votre débat à l'instant c'est que la la
phase ensuite de jugement on a
l'impression qu'on redescend que
finalement aprèsavoir des moyens
d'enquête exceptionnels on redescend et
qu'on on est jugé pardonnez-moi cette
expression encore une fois à la papa
avec des parlementaires qui V des
décalage entre les moyens de la justice
avant le procès enquête très très
monumentale et finalement les jugements
vous étiez dans plusieurs cours de
justice de la République récente vous
l'avez vu on est dans l'affaire la garde
sur une dispense de peine il y a eu des
relaxes dans l'affaire baladure dans
l'affaire Urvoas on a eu une
condamnation qui a été prononcée d'un
mois avec surc on on est sur quelque
chose de beaucoup plus faible et ce
contraste entre une ce qui est vécu
comme une grande violence judiciaire et
ensuite un jugement qui paraît euh
beaucoup plus teinté de de de
bienveillance effectivement montre qu'il
y a quelque chose qui ne fonctionne pas
mais c'est exactement votre illustration
sur l'équilibre du pouvoir en réalité et
l'équilibre l'équilibre des méthodes
pour terminer ce ce débat l'ONG
Transparency internationale appelle à
créer aussi un
déontologue du gouvernement pour
examiner systématiquement les conflits
d'intérêts potentiel des ministres
nouvellement nommés c'est normalement je
pensais le rôle de la fameuse aute
autorité mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un
petit problème de de moyen pour
véritablement à l'américaine à chaque
nomination vérifier le patrimoine mais
aussi les intérêts je je crois très
sincèrement que les organes ont existe
déjà et on les a déjà donc il s'agit de
ne pas réinventer la roue à chaque fois
qu'il y a qu'il y a une affaire et c'est
tout à fait normal de voir s'il existe
des conflits ou non chez les membres du
gouvernement donc cet organe il existe
il faut peut-être regarder s'il est
assez efficace je crois qu'il fonctionne
en tant que parlementaire je suis soumis
à la ha à la Haute Autorité de la
transparence de la vie politique et
c'est très bien c'est très bien le mot
de la fin Charles de Courson l'homme
d'expérience ah ben je crois que on a
vécu
pendant presque que de siècles sur
l'idée de la Révolution
française contre le gouvernement des
juges comme on disait puis que du temps
de la royauté qui s'opposait à
l'absolutisme royal et ben c'était les
magistrats qui disaent le roi n'a pas le
droit de faire cela c'est contraire aux
lois dites fondamental donc il faudrait
revenir à une vraie séparation des
pouvoirs pour vous et donc en réaction
on a dit les élus he les ministres et C
ne relèvent plus voz c'est pour pour ça
que la réformme 93 c'est quand même un
vrai progrès par rapport à ce qui
existait avant et moi je crois qu'il
faut l'achever en disant on va vers le
droit commun comme ça il y aura plus
d'accusation c'est dit les arguments
sont sur la table je suis sûre qu'il va
voilà avoir des conséquences ce débat la
BAL est dans vos quand à vous deux
puisque vous dites que c'est possible
d'ici la fin de de ce quinquena merci
beaucoup merci d'être venu débattre sur
LCP vous restez avec moi Delphine ha
dans une dizaine de minutes les parties
prid nous affranchiss ce soir faut-il
quitter Twitter s'interroge Cécilia
gabizon dans le sillage de la décision
d'Anny dalgo la flambbée des SUV qui
fait tâche à la veille de la COP 28 ce
sera avec Thomas lestaval et puis de
quoi nous parlez-vous ce soir Stéphanie
Despierre dans Bourbon express de la
ligne dure choisie par les républicains
dans le débat sur l'immigration très
bien à tout de suite les amis mais
d'abord on va plonger dans votre combat
la diplomatie fémininiste que vous
comparez donc à un sport de combat c'est
votre premier livre chez taayandier
Delphino Delphine ambassadrice du droit
des femmes dans le monde qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça mérite une explication
c'est l'invitation de Clément per et on
en parle toutes les deux juste
après si on vous invite Delphino c'est
pour parler de ce que vous appelez un
sport de combat non ce n'est pas la boxe
pas plus que la lutte ou le SO encore
moins le MMA c'est de la folie non le
sport de combat que vous pratiquez c'est
la diplomatie
féministe c'est ring les estrades et les
couloir des grandes institutions votre
livre explique comment les droits des
femmes sont attaqués et défendus sur la
scène international un terrain de lutte
que vous connaissez bien ambassadrice du
cador depuis 2019 vous avez dans votre
carrière parcouru le monde
d'institutions publiques en S tank privé
d'associations locales en grandes ONG de
New York à tand et Kabou en passant par
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
juste après la première élection
d'Emmanuel Macron que pouvons-nous faire
nous la France nous l'Union européenne
face à ce
défi militante en marche de la première
heure vous faites partie de celles et
ceux qui ont lancé en France le concept
de diplomatie féministe lancé en Suède
en 2014 par la ministre des Affaires
étrangères Margot valro la France porte
une diplomatie féministe ambitieuse dans
toute toutes les enceintes et sur tous
les terrains la diplomatie féministe
pratiquée aujourd'hui par 12 pays dans
le monde consiste à toujours prendre en
compte la question des droits des femmes
dans les relations diplomatiques et la
résolution des conflits face au coup de
bouttoir des forces régressives une
action concertée systématique et
mobilisatrice et nécessaire les
gouvernements progressistes doivent
remonter les droits des femmes dans
l'agenda de leur priorités stratégiques
dans votre livre vous dénoncez le
backlash ou retour de bâton en français
on appelle ainsi l'alliance des
gouvernements antiféministes qui
voudrait revenir sur certains droits
vous insistez aussi sur le rôle que peut
jouer la lutte pour les droits des
femmes pour résoudre certains conflits
comme au Liberia ou en Colombie alors ce
soir à l'heure où les conflits
s'intensifie en Ukraine et au Proche
Orient on vous pose la question la paix
peut-elle venir des
femmes réponse
d'pine elles sont moins béliqueuses
elles sont plus aptes à à maintenir et à
construire la la paix les femmes pas par
essentialisme biologique il n'y a rien
dans nos gèes qui fait que nous sommes
plus prédisposés à la paix en revanche
il y a un certain nombre d'études qui le
montrre et j'en parle dans les livres
que lorsque les femmes sont assises à la
table des négociations dont elles ont
été historiquement exclues la durabilité
des accord de paix est supérieure à des
accords de paix qui auraient été
négociés que par des hommes et encore
une fois ce n'est pas une PR
prédisposition bi c'est uniquement parce
que les femmes sont
sociologiquement construites édué
formé pour se projeter dans le long
terme pour dans la plupart des sociétés
y compris occidental s'occuper des
enfants et donc avoir une vision
beaucoup plus de long terme et je donne
notamment l'exemple de la Colombie donc
c'est le seul exemple au monde dans
l'histoire du monde où les femmes ont
véritablement été associées au processus
de paix entre le gouvernement colombien
et les farces il y avait une
sous-commission genre dans ces
négociationsl et c'est important de
rappeler aussi que les femmes ne sont
pas seulement les victimes des conflits
mais elles en sont aussi des
combattantes et dans le cas de la
Colombie il il y avait 40 % des
guerriers Ros colombiens des pH qui
étaient en fait des guerriers race et
qui est donc des femmes pendant des
années les diplomates ont parlerit des
droits de l'homme ou encore des droits
humains plus récemment dans chaque
rencontre internationale à partir de
quand les droits des femmes en tant que
tell deviennent un véritable objet dans
les dans les discussions dans les
conventions entre état c'est
effectivement beaucoup plus récent que
la création des Nations Unies à la fin
des années 40 à la fin de la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en fait c'est à partir
de la fin des années 70 et vraiment la
décennie d'or c'est la décennie 80 les
décénnies 90 où on va avoir une grande
série de conférences internationales des
nations- Unies qui vont avoir pour
objectif principal de promouvoir les
droits des femmes de réduire les
inégalités politiques sociales et
économiques et qui vont aboutir à un
corpus de grandes conventions
international de textes qui sont
aujourd'hui le fondement de notre droit
international qui d'ailleurs va
déteindre sur notre droit national ou
notre droit européen mais aujourd'hui ce
qu'on voit c'est que ces grandes
conventions internationales ce ce socle
de droits fondamentaux ils sont remis en
question ils sont remis en cause voir
directement attaqués par un certain
nombre de pays de partis politiques de
mouvements certains d'inspirations
religieus d'autres plus politiqu qui
vont batailler et c'est l'objet de ce
sport de combat diplomatique à l'ONU
dans l'Union européenne dans toutes les
organisations multilatérales pour faire
régresser ces droits voilà c'est très
frappant de voir que au fond tous les
Ultra conservateurs les réactionnaires
et pas seulement dans les pays du Sud
les pays plus pauvres que le Nord
occidental sont sont présents c'est le
fameux backlash le retour de bâton
postmou révolution rétrograde on peut le
dire comme ça antiprogrès antifm
antiinorité antilgbt et vous montrez
très bien qu'ils sont très puissants ces
mouvementsl qu'ils financent à à coup de
milliard aussi bien leur propre pays on
pense à la Pologne aux États-Unis mais
aussi la lutte contre le droit à
l'avortement dans les pays du Sud oui
oui effectivement et c'est un sujet qui
est peu connu du grand public c'est
vraiment la raison pour laquelle j'ai
voulu écrire ce livre c'est un peu tirer
la sonette d'alarme puce que on voit ça
et là des émergences de ce mouvement
tout le monde a été choqué de l'arrêt
rovy Wade aux États-Unis donc la
suppression du droit constitutionnelle
la protection constitutionnelle à
l'avortement on sait un peu ce qui s'est
passé en Pologne en Hongrie on a V ce
qui s'est passé au Brésil dans d'autres
pays mais on ne se rend pas compte en
réalité que tout ça ce ne sont pas des
phénomènes qui sont arrivés par hasard
de manière totalement indépendante en
réalité à la justement à la fin des
années 90 il y a une frange de la
population notamment des partis
politiques et des organisations
religieuses inspirées en partie par le
Vatican et par les églises évangélistes
nord-américaines qui ont décidé de
rentrer dans cette guerre des cultures
d't guerre des valeurs en disant on est
allé trop loin c'est contraire à nos
valeurs patriarcales réactionnaire et
cetera qui ont financé des mouvements
politiques qui ont financé des campagnes
politiques aux États-Unis c'est comme ça
qu'on est arrivé avec une cour suprême
avec une majorité très réactionnaire et
quand on voit ce qui se passe dans un
certain nombre de pays en Afrique vous
citiez les pays du Sud récemment en
Uganda au Ghana où on a des lois qui ont
été votées qui répriment par la peine de
mort l'homosexualité ou des personnes
qui auraient connaissance d'autres
personnes homosexuel tout cela a été
financé en fait directement par des
églises évangélistes nord-américaines
donc il y a des is entre Nord et Sud
pour faire reculer le droit des femes AC
financiers qui ont été vraiment traqués
par un certain nombre de de rapport que
je cite dans le livre il y a aussi des
grandes fondations philanthropiques
français espagnoles européenne
d'inspiration en général
catholique alors je les cite pas dans
dans le livre mais vous pouvez vous
référer notamment au rapport du forum
parlementaire européen pour les droits
sexuels et reproductifs si c'est trop
long vous pouvez le trouver dans le
livre qui en en fait a créé à à a
dessiné cette constellation euh il y a
eu pendant un certain moment aussi des
financements de de de de de riches
milliardaires orthodoxes russes qui
venaient aussi financer ces mouvements
antidroits en Europe l'Europe a les
moyens de se défendre en fait on
aimerait comprendre euh concrètement euh
quels sont nos résultats de cette
diplomatie féministe qui n'est défini
nulle part hein dans aucun traité mais
qui pays après pays crée des groupe pour
essayer de de faire avancer les droits
quels sont quels sont vos résultats
qu'est-ce que fait la France qu'est-ce
qu'elle obtient très concrètement pour
défendre ces droit là bah la diplomatie
féministe et c'est pour ça que je
souhaitais que le titre soit dans dans
le titre du livre parce que justement je
sais que c'est un un concept qui peut
paraître totalement abscond ou bizarre
ou incompréhensible pour le grand public
c'est simplement reconnaître pour nos
diplomaties donc nos gouvernements que
les droits des femmes sont un enjeu
géopolitique stratégique politique de
premier plan ça n'est pas juste un enjeu
de dévelop veloppement évidemment il y a
aussi la question de l'accès à la santé
l'accès à l'éducation et cetera mais
aujourd'hui on a été entraîné en fait
sur ce terrain de lutte véritablement
qui est une lutte qui est diplomatique
hein qui n'est pas armée et militaire
qui pourrait peut-être l'être un jour
mais on a perdu du terrain sur les
droits qui avaient été acquis dans les
années 80 80 90 2000 et il faut qu'on se
mobilise donc la France par exemple
est-ce qu'elle peut aider des femmes en
danger être extradées les protéger la
France peut par exemple conditionner FA
ses aides financières à un pays et
l'obliger à avancer sur les droits
sociaux les droits politiques les droits
élémentaires des femmes c'est c'est ce
qu'a fait à contrario un certain nombre
de pays notamment les États-Unis sous
Donald Trump qui on en fait coupé
intégralement toute leur aide public au
développement à toutes les organisations
qui ne serait-ce que mentionner soit le
droit à l'avortement soit même le droit
à la contraception et aujourd'hui il
faut arrêter d'être naïf il faut être
très réaliste et pragmatique là-dessus
donc on mène un travail à l'ONU dans les
grandes enceintes organisation
internationale pour défendre ses droits
et on mène un travail de terrain aussi
donc je voudrais citer un certain nombre
d'initiatives qu'on a pu lancer
récemment l'initiative Marianne pour les
défenseurs des droits de l'Homme donc
qui qui élit ou qui sélectionne une
promotion une quinzaine de défenseurs
des droits humains chaque année la
première promotion en 2021 était
intégralement féminine donc c'est donc
des femmes des militantes féministes de
terrain qui venaient d' un peu partout
dans le monde qu'on fait venir en France
avec une bourse des programmes de
soutien un logement à qui on facilite
aussi
le droit d'asile en France il y a le
prix Simon veille de la République il y
a aussi des actions qui sont très
importantes qui sont menées sur les
victimes de violen sexuell dans les
conflits on y viendra peut-être puisque
aujourd'hui malheureusement il y a une
résurgence des
conflits et donc on a soutenu le fond
mondial pour les survivantes de violence
sexuelle dans les conflits qui avait été
lancé en 2019 par le docteur mokegé oui
docteur qui recou les femmes excisées
vous parlez aussi de du féminisme dans
l'écologie on connaît l'éch féminisme
popularisé par Sandrine Rousseau entre
autres et et vous faites un lien entre
femmes et réchauffement climatique en
quoi sont-elles plus vulnérables que les
hommes alors les femmes c'est à la fois
les premières victimes euh du
réchauffement climatique et ce sont les
premières actrices de la résilience
contre le réchauffement climatique
pourquoi les premières victimes euh il
faut se se se se projeter dans des pays
du Sud où les femmes sont encore 70 %
des agricultrices c'est-à-dire que ce
sont elles qui travaillent la la terre
les ressources naturelles qui les euh
qui les récolteent qui vont aller
chercher le bois pour le chauffage pour
la cuisine et cetera et qui sont donc
touchés de plein fouet par les
conséquences de la désertification de
l'augmentation des températures des
tsunamis de l'augmentation des des
océans et cetera et cetera elle
représente 80 % des réfugiés climatiques
dans le monde c'est énorme et on sait
que lorsqu'il y a une catastrophe
naturelle un tsunami euh un ouragan et
cetera en fait elles meurt à des à des
pourcentages de 14 fois plus elles sont
14 fois plus susceptibles de mourir ou
d'être touché par une catastrophe
climatique parce que souvent elles n'ont
pas les moyens économiques elles n'ont
pas de voiture elles n'ont pas le moyens
de se déplacer elles sont obligées de
rester sur place pour s'occuper des
enfants des personnes âgées dans
beaucoup de cultures et de beaucoup de
pays on n'accepte pas qu'elle soit seule
dans un dans un lieu d'accueil des
réfugiés parce qu'elles doivent être
accompagné par un homme et cetera et
cetera donc elles sont vraiment celles
qui vivent de plein fouet cette
transition ce réchauffement climatique
et en même temps c'est ce sont elles qui
ont les solutions hm hm et je voudrais
qu'on parle évidemment des des femmes
victimes des conflits puisque
l'actualité en témoigne victime de viol
comme arme de guerre le 7 octobre dans
les massacres du Hamas en Israël il y a
eu un crime particulier sur les femmes
israéliennes on va regarder cette image
c'est un crime dans le crime qui a été
noncé dénoncé par le collectif nous
vivrons qui était place de la Nation on
les voit ici avec leurs pancartes violé
mutilés tués par le Hasque
qu'attendez-vous pour agir elle
s'adresse aux féministes bien
silencieuses he qui n'ont on pas
véritablement permis de de défiler avec
les autres collectifs c'était dimanche
dernier pour la grande marche contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes parce
que leur sécurité n'était pas garantie
et puis vous le voyez à New York devant
le siège de l'ONU peut-être que ça n'a
pas été choisi par hasard ce silence des
féministes dénoncé aussi après le 7
[Musique]
octobre
voilà des femmes qui crient shame on you
est-ce qu'il y a eu un silence coupable
des des grandes voies féministes des
organisations féministes onufemme après
le 7 octobre sur les crimes sexuels
commis sur les israéliennes alors
effectivement c'est vrai que le le
conflit en Israël Palestine aujourd'hui
et les massacres du Hamas du 7 octobre
ont créé un certain nombre de divisions
au sein du mouvement féministe c'est pas
la première le premier sujet qui crée
des divisions au sein de ce mouvement ce
qui est intéressant de noter c'est que
assez rapidement donc les les les les
les rapports qui ont été faits par
l'armée israélienne ont permis
d'identifier effectivement l'utilisation
des violences sexuelles et notamment du
viol comme arme de guerre pendant très
longtemps ça a été un sujet qui était
totalement inaperçu qui passait comme
totalement normal dans les guerres il
était tout à fait ça ce sont les faits
mais le silence des féministes qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez alors je d'abord je
voudrais revenir sur la marche de de du
25 novembre la plupart des grandes
organisations féministes se sont
exprimées notamment la Fondation des
femmes par la voix de la présidente qui
avait dès les premiers jours d'octobre
réagi de manière très vive par rapport à
ça nous la question aujourd'hui qu'on se
pose nous en tant que diplomate c'est
évidemment lutter contre l'impunité ce
qu'on a fait ce qu'on fait notamment en
Ukraine euh puisque vous citiez aussi
l'Ukraine donc on soutient l'action de
la Cour pénale internationale pour
recueillir des preuves le plus
rapidement possible des femmes
ukrainiennes qui ont été victimes de
violence par des soldats russes on
soutient aussi le fond mondial du
docteur mukwegé pour donner des
réparations à la à fois psychologique et
économique et sur les familles
israéliennes est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment que ces crimes par les
féministes ont été de façon un peu vocal
dénoncé ou pas suffisamment ça dépend
évidemment des des organisations je
pense que ça alla été en tout cas par
les États et par les gouvernement et on
essaie d'avoir une action particulière
sur ce sujet de l'autre côté aussi sur
la crise humanitaire qui a lieu à Gaza
en ce moment on essaie d'intensifier
notre soutien aux femmes et aux enfants
qui sont les premières victimes civiles
de de la de la guerre qui a lieu en ce
moment en tout cas ce que je veux
montrer dans le livre et alors il a été
écrit avant ce qui s'est passé
aujourd'hui c'est que il y a un certain
nombre de conflits aussi oubliés comme
le Yémen la Libye l'Afghanistan et
cetera dont personne ne parle et où les
femmes ont été totalement absentes aussi
des négociation de paix la la diplomatie
féministe est un sport de combat les
droits des femmes un enjeu mondial merci
beaucoup Delphin c'est àire aux éditions
Taillandier et je suis sûr que la jeune
génération trouvera plein d'idées pour
leur son avenir en vous lisant merci
vous restez avec moi c'est l'heure de
retrouver les affranchis pour leur
partie prix vous vous faire réagir au
les accueil tout de suite Cécilia
gabizon pour son billet société
directrice des rédaction du groupe média
ETX magéan bienvenue Thomas Lestavel
journaliste économique on retrouve avec
plaisir installez-vous on commence comme
chaque soir par Bourbon Express
l'histoire du jour à l'Assemblée c'est
vous Stéphanie des pierres qui nous l'a
raconté bonsoir Stéphanie bonsoir et je
vous raconte la stratégie de fermeté des
républicains sur l'immigration en pleine
discussion de la loi d'armanin les
députés de la commission des lois ont
ouvert une parenthèse de quelques heures
ce matin pour étudier un autre texte
celui d'Éric cioti qui propose de
réviser la Constitution un préalable
essentiel pour lutter contre
l'immigration à entendre le patron des
républicains les 29 lois immigration qui
se sont succédés depuis
1981 n'ont rien changé plus il y a
d'immigration
plus il y a de loi plus il y a de loi
plus il y a d'immigration il est donc
impératif de changer de cadre juridique
de changer de modèle de changer de
méthode en face les trois groupes du
camp présidentiel refuse de toucher à la
constitution la gauche elle pilonene une
proposition mortifère pour les droits
fondamentaux le rassemblement national
aussi qui préfère ses idées à la copie
ce sont leurs mots des républicains
alors sans sur prise le texte a échoué
mais les républicains restent
inflexibles pas de révision de la
Constitution pas de vote de droite pour
la loi immigration le problème c'est que
cette stratégie de l'état-major des
républicains est loin d'être partagée
par toute la droite en interne oui myiam
après les division sur la réforme des
retraites les républicains espéraient
afficher un visage uni sur l'immigration
et bien c'est raté tout a déjà volé en
éclat c'est le retour de la droite façon
puzzle avant même que le débat ne
commence dans l'hémicycle l'intrésigence
d'Olivier marlex et d'Éric cioti
vis-à-vis du gouvernement est très
contesté et une partie des députés est
mal à l'aise comment justifier de voter
contre une loi qui contient des mesures
de fermeté pour réguler l'immigration
alors que ça plaît à certains électeurs
LR alors dimanche 17 députés ont publié
une tribune pour montrer qu'ils étaient
constructifs bancau pour la loi
immigration à condition que la version
du Sénat ne soit pas trop détricotée et
dans cette tribune il y a aussi un autre
message plus subliminal comme me l'a
raconté une des signataires quand je
signe la tribune ça ne veut pas dire que
je vote forcément le texte immigration
mais en revanche ça veut dire clairement
que je ne signe pas une motion de
censure or la motion de censure c'est la
menace brandi depuis septembre par
Olivier marlex patron des députés mais
l'hypothèse se dégonfle myiam car à
l'URE qu'il est on voit mal comment il
arrivera à trouver 58 signaires sur ses
62 députés pour la déposer il y en a un
qui se délecte de la tribune des
constructifs LR c'est géralde Darman
j'imagine évidemment le ministre de
l'Intérieur il voit un encouragement un
signe qu'il peut convaincre des députés
les républicains et passer sa loi 1493
alors il accentue la pression sur ses
anciens collègues et active ses relais
au sein du groupe les républicains et
ses conseillers font pareil cet
après-midi encore on a croisé Grégory
canal dans les couloirs de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est le conseiller
parlementaire du ministre de l'Intérieur
lui aussi ancien républicain il était en
pleine discussion avec une député les
républicains merci beaucoup Stéphanie je
suis pas sûr que ça vous manque trop he
toutes ces manœuvres politiciennes vous
l'ancienne député Delphino on enchaîne
avec vous Cécilia bonsoir Cécilia
Gabison voulez revenir sur cette affaire
an nidalgo la nouvelle n'est pas du tout
passée inaperçue puisque la mère de
Paris a décidé de claquer haut et fort
la porte de X ex Twitter devenu selon
elle un vaste égût mondial elle n'est
d'ailleurs pas la seule à avoir déserté
le réseaux social alors j'ai pris la
décision de quitter Twitter pas moi
anidalgo car loin d'être l'outil
révolutionnaire qui au départ permettait
un accès à l'information au plus grand
nombre est devenu ces dernières années
l'arme de destruction massive de nos
démocraties a-t-elle écrit dans une
tribune bon peut-être une façon de
changer un petit peu le sujet après
Tahiti mais aussi un vrai choix
puisqu'elle fait une croix sur 1,5
million d'abonnés et dans la classe
politique beaucoup s'interrogent sur que
faire alors si les politique hésite les
marques elles en tout cas un certain
nombre de marques américaines notamment
ont décidé de suspendre leur budget
publicitaire sur Twitter IBM Apple
Disney Verner Bros notamment pourquoi
alors entre tout le le Chahu autour de
Twitter mais c'est surtout les le
dernier fait de Elon Musk qui a soutenu
un tweet carrément antisémite qui disait
en gros que les juif manœuvra pour
promouvoir la haine des blancs et en
fait elon mus n'a rien trouvé de mieux
que d'écrire et c'est la vérité alors
après ça ça a été quand même un tolé car
c'est vraiment un classique de
l'antisémitisme et du coup en fait ces
marques ont retiré leur budget pub
depuis elon est en Israel il essaie
d'arranger les choses mais Twitter reste
pas Twitter x reste dans la tourmente
oui alors il faut dire que c'est
évidemment depuis son rachat par Elon
Musk en avril 2022 que ce à la fois les
internautes se sent moins bien que le
réseau lui-même est dans la tourmente
car ça c'était le le dernier épisode de
beaucoup de changements sur Twitter a
commencé par le changement de nom il y
avait ce nom Twitter un verbe tweeter et
c'est devenu X mais c'est nom tellement
ridicule qu'on est systématiquement
obligé de dire ex Twitter ensuite il a
limogé tout une grande partie des
équipes qui faisaient la modération hors
sur ces plateformes sans modération B ça
ça concentre finalement des complotistes
des radicaux des fondamentalistes et
donc c'est devenu en fait une un forum
où prévale pas mal évidemment il y a
d'autres choses mais de messages haineux
ouais le défouloir massif de la haine
mais pourtant on nserve pas un départ
massif du réseau non parce que comme on
l'avait d'ailleurs vu avec d'autres
réseaux sociaux a eu des problèmes on a
construit des habitudes une sociabilité
des amitiés en fait sur ces réseaux et
donc c'est difficile de de faire une
croix sur 15 ans d'amitié de
communication 20 minutes à posé la
question au députés ils ont dit mais on
a tous nos abonnés donc on a du mal
aussi à perdre un canal de communication
mais certains médias ont commencé à à
lâcher Twitter notamment la radio
publique américaine NPR et en fait 6
mois après ben il ne s'est rien passé
ils n'ont pas perdu trafic et donc en
fait ça a été minime parce que d'autant
que aujourd'hui le trafic des médias
déjà qui vient de Twitter a énormément
diminué de par tous ces allés- venu
changement sur Twitter donc c'est plus
la porte que c'était alors ce que ça dit
quand même c'est que aujourd'hui en
France on passe en moyenne 57 minutes
par jour sur Twitter ce ne sont pas les
jeunes mais surtout les boomers les plus
50 ans qui sont sur Twitter et qui
écrivent des tweets mais que pour les
gens qui ont arrêté les réseaux sociaux
vous savez que c'est un thème qui
revient régulièrement en fait il y en a
de plus en plus la alors les études sont
variées sur le sujet ce que ça montre
c'est que globalement ça leur fait
plutôt du bien et un point important il
va devenir de plus en plus important de
contrôler à qui et à quoi vous donnez
votre temps de cerveau ceci étant dit
j'aimerais remercier la personne qui
fait les tweets de LCP qui sont toujours
excellent quelle chute on lui dit merci
au passage pour l'instant vous êtes sur
stter j'ai vérifié on verra si vous
quittez ou pas Thomas il nous reste un
peu moins de temps on va faire un peu
plus court mais vous vouliez revenir sur
une décision de la mairie de Paris vous
aviez poussé un coup de gueule contre
les trottinettes je me rappelle dans la
dans la capitale cette fois et bien Anne
hiidalgo propose aux habitants un
station plus cher pour les SUV
SUV oui tout fait Miriam alors je suis
pas particulièrement fan d' d'an dalgo
mais encore une fois je crois que je
vais voter pour alors les SUV on connaît
c'est un type de voiture qui est très
très populaire en fait ça représente
maintenant la moitié du marché français
et bientôt 2 tiers en 2030 donc c'est
des véhicules comme la Peugeot 3008 le
cashqai ou le BMW X5 alors c'est des
modèles ça se justifie totalement pour
une famille qui a plusieurs enfants mais
par contre pour les autres personnes
c'est un non sens écologique pourquoi
alors le problème c'est que beaucoup de
d'automobilistes en achè des SUV alors
qu'ils sont seuls à bord c'est c'est
vraiment frappant parce qu'en fait le
taux de natalité continue de décliner
mais il y a une chose qui n'arrête pas
d'augmenter depuis 10 ans c'est le poids
des véhicules ils prennent 10 kg en
moyenne chaque année un phénomène qu'on
appelle l'autobésité et qui dis voiture
plus lourd dit évidemment plus de
carburant pour les déplacer c'est plus
20 % en moyenne pour les SUV alors
l'association WWF a sorti un rapport
très éclairant sur le sujet et la
conclusion est sans appel la France
n'atteindra pas ses objectifs
climatiques si elle ne réduit pas les de
SUV la COP 28 la grand messe de la
transition écologique ça commence demain
ils ont à peine prévu d'en parler et
pourtant si on additionnait tous les SUV
de la planète ça donnerait le 6e pays le
plus polluant au monde ouais bon
l'électrification les voitures
électriques ça va tout régler non alors
ça c'est l'argument phare mais non
malheureusement non c'est pas une
solution magique parce que une voiture
quand elle est plus lourde qu'elle soit
thermique électrique hydrogène que
sais-je elle va consommer plus et
Greenpeace a sorti aujourd'hui même une
étude super intéressante là-dessus ils
ont analysé trois grands constructeurs
Hyundai Volkswagen Toyota et ils ont
conclu que la croissance de leur vente
de SUV annulé annilé pardon annulé donc
les gains climatiques qui provenaient de
leur véhicule électrique ah oui bon
c'est inquiétant ce que vous nous
racontez est-ce que ces véhicules
modernes sont plus sûrs au moins il
donnent une impression de sécurité pour
ceux qui sont à bord mais en réalité ils
sont moins sûrs ils sont plus dangereux
un piéton a deux fois plus de chance
d'être tué en cas de collision avec un
SUV par rapport à un véhicule classique
et d'après le très sérieux Journal of
safety research le risque est multiplié
par 8 pour un enfant donc si on résume
le SUV c'est une abération écologique et
sociale pour les familles ok mais pour
les autres il faut dissuader et c'est
pour ça que je voterai pour
l'interdiction et ben voilà en voilà
vous faites au moins une heureuse à
nidalgo ce soir merci beaucoup non au
SUV mais vous restez sur X c'estd merci
les affranchis merci pour vos parti prix
à très vite Stéphanie et Merci à VOUS
Delphino d'être passé sur le plateau d'
LCP la diplomatie féministe est un sport
de combat c'est àdire chez taayandier
très belle soirée documentaire avec
Jean-Pierre gracien à
[Musique]
demain